I think it was Macbeth who said if music
be the spice of life then I love it
[ __ ] either way my allowance of
employees to listen to reasonably volume
to music means productivity in the
workplace has never been greater yeah
get it again vincible with you by my
side just stay away from that Nicki
Minaj though okay she's a bad influence
on you bag take me away from here
soundscapes bye Lana freed oh I'm so
much more productive when I picture
myself in a bangle he's jungle being
waited on hand and foot by day laborers
this is the life I think he's always
been let's close together
I'm thirsty I'm doing good work today do
I use my pinky or my ring finger less
this is good work coffee is good work
it's good things are good good working
today Anna good working yes yes more
music
Coachella is happening in my cubicle
who's not cool enough to get enough rent
now finally takes me putting on broken
earbuds for these clowns to leave me
alone hey did you hear the new with your
two thirsty office two thirsty
yes music is vital to our productivity
as for me I don't need to listen to
music it lives within me I'm filled to
the brim with it and I have been ever
since starring as Harold Hill and a
genderbent version of Meredith Willson's
The Music Man weird trouble little guy
right here is a trouble my inner Creek
Township why always had a tennis
this isn't music just to drown out
Natalie she sounds like my grandma my
grandma with asthma